well it's a real privilege to be here
Stanford's technology of interest
programs
inspiration to generations of people and
Tina in particular is my inspiration
she's the go-to person about learning
about creativity which is really
critical for what we're doing so I want
to talk to you today about Olin where it
came from and and what we've learned so
it's sort of the outline for the talk
and the first is about the founding of
Olin and let me point out that this is a
picture of Franklin Olin who's the guy
who created the revenue that generated
Olin College
he's a Cornell graduate 1880s he retired
in 1938 from the Olin corporation he
died in 1951 but his legacy is what
created Olin so for example there are 78
buildings on 58th University campuses
that say Olin Hall so there's an Olin
Hall for example at Vanderbilt
there's an Olin hall at Cornell there's
an Olin Hall at University of Southern
California and dozens and dozens of
other places the Olin foundation decided
to end that grants program and to start
over in higher ed entirely because
there's a great deal of unhappiness
about the way engineers are prepared you
see if there are lots of surveys that
show that if you talk to presidents and
professors at universities about whether
the graduates are well prepared to enter
the workforce there's a very high
percentage of them that say of course
we've never done a better job of
preparing graduates for the workforce
but on the other hand if you talk to
people in corporations about how well
the graduates are prepared for entering
the workforce they have a different
opinion okay and these opinions are sort
of diverging because they're not talking
to each other very well
that's what the Olin foundation was
worried about so this is sort of a
timeline for how the school started 1997
they came up with the Charter 1999 first
employee that's me okay so when I showed
up at Olin it was not yet a place it was
an idea the Olin foundation consisted of
four people and me okay none of them is
an engineer and none of them has ever
worked in higher education but they had
very strong ideas about what needs to
change you know what can go wrong with
this right so it was a very interesting
couple of years as we work through this
now they had a lot of experience in
working buildings and so they basically
said I'll do everything else so you
don't go find the people we'll figure
out what the curriculum is by the way
you need to rethink what it means to be
an engineer and rethink what it means to
be educated in the 21st century and
let's do it all over again oh there's
some other things no tenure no
departments everything has an expiration
date including the curriculum and
students won't pay for the educational
experience that was the original plan
for the school the most important thing
on this is 2001 the Olin Partner year
that's probably and it's sort of
accidental the way it worked but it's
the most important thing we did so what
happened is we brought in 15 boys and 15
girls who lived in construction trailers
on a parking lot for a year they were
not taking courses and they were not
employees so we just called them
partners ok and we have to have them
because you can't pretend that you don't
know how to sell solve the calculus
problem and make a judgment about
whether method a is more successful than
Method B you actually have to have some
people who've never solved the calculus
problem so you can talk to them while
they're doing it and we did experiments
during that year that's what changed
everything most important thing we
learned almost without exception young
people are more capable of learning
things on their own than we ever
expected in we basically structure the
educational program probably everywhere
probably in every grade too much and it
pretends it begins to put people in
boxes and extinguish creativity so the
person who is most responsible for
starting the schools
Larry Milas who said there's a lot of
unhappiness today about the way
engineering is taught the principal
advisors for this at the beginning were
Joseph Bardonia who was the chief
operating officer at NSF who had run
something called the engineering
education coalition's program for a
decade spent over a hundred million
dollars trying to motivate you
to rethink engineering and gave up
because the data showed it doesn't work
they're not changing the other person is
John Prados who was the chair of the
Accreditation Board that changed the
entire accreditation criteria because
universities have forever said what we
would change but you know the
Accreditation Board wouldn't give us
accreditation so you can't do this so
John re-engineered the accreditation
criteria so that's no longer true you
can do Olin is fully accredited we've
never had any problem with it with abet
accreditation so that's not the issue
so in the founding precepts of the
school is this description of hawai
these folks spent almost five hundred
million dollars to start an entirely new
institution and basically what they said
the college is intended to be different
not for the mere sake of being different
but to become an important and constant
contributor to the advancement of
engineering education in America and
throughout the world
in other words Olin College is intended
to be an education laboratory
so we're basically a privately funded
National Laboratory for STEM education
redesign that's what the school is about
what does that mean I think this picture
captures it higher education is this
giant aircraft carrier that's hard to
reposition Olin is a tugboat that's
pushing it 90 degrees trying to get it
to move a little bit to the left or a
little bit to the right and that's what
we do so we've been visited by 640
universities since 2009 we've had
significant partnerships with everybody
on this page and many others as well and
as a result of that for example our
partnership with the University of
Illinois at urbana-champaign resulted in
a complete redesign of their
undergraduate program all 1,600 incoming
engineering students at Illinois now
take a different program that was
co-designed with Olin and that resulted
in this book which is co-authored by a
senior faculty member Illinois and at
Olin okay so that's an illustration
that's enough about Olin okay now I want
to tell you what we've learned about
engineering education in about 15 years
of experimentation it's just a very
different kind of
of set of messages the first thing
that's happened is that we've noticed
that there's a a trend in higher
education over time there's changes
going on at the sort of mega scale the
first one is what is often been called
the knowledge economy so at at Olin
we've noticed that there's an unspoken
assumption about education probably for
500 years and then simply the more you
know the better your life will be okay
that's why we send our kids to school so
if we just send them to school they
learn lots of stuff
trust me their life will be better
however that's actually a testable
hypothesis and James Heckman who's a
Nobel prize-winning economist the
University of Chicago has tested it the
correlation between how much you know
and how well your life turns out to be
is not very good okay in fact a three
times better predictor a positive life
outcomes then either knowledge or
intelligence is what is called grit what
is grit it's a combination of passion
and perseverance it's attitudes
behaviors and motivations it's not
knowledge okay but nevertheless
everybody does this the knowledge
economy is about putting content into
kids heads right that's what we do
that's why I have a PhD because you're
the expert you stand in front of people
in a classroom they take notes and at
the end of the day this is a sage on the
stage model rows of seats and a
blackboard is how you organize them you
know if it worked by finding out what
they know so we sort of imagine this as
testing at the end a little bit like a
giant jeopardy game okay so everybody
raises these questions if you get most
of the questions right we put a big
check in the box higher education it's
done this thing we're doing well there's
a problem with this it's called Google
now while you're taking the Jeopardy
exam
somebody's googling the answer and they
get it before you did and they didn't go
to school at all this changes everything
now the value proposition of just
knowing stuff
has changed probably permanently and
we're in the middle right now the
transition to what I call the maker
economy so it's not about what you know
it's about what you can do with what you
know this is a completely different
paradigm so we're now not just putting
stuff into kids heads we're expecting
some stuff to come out too and so you
might think of this maker economy you're
learning how to play the clarinet so as
a result you you watch somebody play the
clarinet and then you try it
it doesn't sound the same so then you
iterate you try to do it a little bit
better imitating what they did until you
build a skill to where you can replicate
what they do or maybe integrating by
parts and you're watching Khan Academy
they do this 17 times with these
problems I got the pattern I'm gonna do
it myself
okay anything you can do by watching
somebody else make your economy so what
happens now is the teachers not the
expert the teacher is the coach okay
it's actually very important you want to
have a coach that's how the coaches are
very important to football for example
so it was basketball the best
organization of students in this case is
not in a large auditorium sitting in
rows but in small groups talking to each
other on some kind of a maker project
you know it could be building a robot
could be writing a book by the way life
is a maker project so learning how to do
this is an important thing now it's not
about what you know it's about what you
can do with what you know this isn't the
end we can foresee what's happening in
the future which is more important which
is what I'd call the innovation economy
now the value proposition is completely
different it's spot comes out of kids
heads that's important it's not I mean
obviously you're still putting stuff in
but what you're paying attention to is
what comes out it's the new ideas we
don't actually know who does the best
teaching here whether it's the teacher
whether it's peers with its mentors it's
that whole environment why because
creativity has less to do with your DNA
than it does with your environment and
it's the community in the ecology of the
environment that really matters
and the method of teaching is probably
associated with intrinsic motivation
and Design Thinking it's our best guess
at this point it's still part of the
research agenda for the future and now
it's about what you conceive now you can
complain and say aren't all of these
things important of course but I can
tell you the evidence that I'm seeing by
talking to our placement office if you
look at where the graduates go and how
much money they get has a surrogate for
the demand the students who get the
largest salaries guess which one of
these three areas they come from it's
the one on the far right okay it's about
the most creative people who conceive
new products who do the sort of
developing new markets is where the
market is okay so that's where this is
going and I want to talk about why
education must change what's driving all
this have you seen this graph this is
the graph of human population over all
of human history two and a half million
years ago okay all the way through you
can see where the black death was at the
B monic plague in 1920 I think there
were two billion people on the planet in
1927 something like that today there are
seven billion we're on the way to 9
billion I don't think there's a single
aspect of human existence on the planet
that won't be affected by that graph the
education system that we're using by the
way was designed way before the peak and
this started this is not taking into
account these changes that by the way
that graph is an existential threat okay
population biologists have seen graphs
like this before like the explosion of
population of rabbits on the plain in
Australia what do they know when it gets
to a graph like that about one
generation later there aren't any more
rabbits usually
the species is extinct if we're going to
avoid that we're going to have to use
the stuff between our ears and to do
things differently in order to manage
what we're what we've created so
the National Academy of Engineering in
the US has been looking ahead at the
kinds of challenges that our species is
going to have to deal with and these are
the sorts of things that they found by
the way these all fit into four major
areas security sustainability health and
the enhancing of life as the number of
people grows these problems are not
technology problems technology has
something to do with all of them in fact
some of the challenges are here because
of the technology the unintended
consequences in the previous generation
nevertheless they're about human
behavior and we have to take human
behavior into account if we're going to
solve any of them so the we have to have
the right people in the room to frame
the problem we can't just have engineers
talking about this we need a broader
community so this involves coupled
scientific social economic political
even religious dimensions because of the
population has to accept it or it
doesn't work what this really means is
that we need a new kind of engineering
innovator
so other populations have faced
extinction and so one of the research
projects we have is just so what did
they do how do they get where they are
so some folks think that maybe the
dinosaurs had trouble with their diet
okay
others think maybe they had some
behavior issues with you know alcohol
tobacco other sorts of things they also
didn't really anticipate security very
well so in this particular group said
all I'm saying is now is the time to
develop technology to deflect an
asteroid and obviously they didn't pay
any attention to that and finally maybe
they missed the boat they just were
distracted you know Noah took off and
they had all the other animals but the
dinosaurs are sitting on the shore they
were playing basketball that day or
something we need to pay attention which
raises the question what exactly is
innovation now there are lots of
definitions of this so the one I want to
talk about is the kind of innovation
that changes the planet
this is not just the kind of innovation
that develops a new product or a new
industry but it changes the way people
live on a very large scale so if you
have a very profound innovation it
changes the way people live so
profoundly that people can't remember
the way life was before it happened
so my kids for example can't imagine how
the caveman lived before the cellphone
I mean they've sort of always been here
so how could you possibly make that work
the point of this is that you have to
implement ideas or you don't change the
way people live
so without implementation it's just an
idea
ideas are cool but innovation requires
adoption of the ideas it requires people
on a large scale to choose it now if you
think about this I think our traditional
model for education may actually be
preventing us from producing innovators
let me explain why so if you graduate
from high school and you go on to
college you need to choose a major this
might be a map of a large State
University campus okay maybe the
dimension of the whole page is a couple
of miles in each dimension and then once
you go to say the engineering school
you're going to spend four years in that
little region of that map which is
called the engineering quad okay that's
where people learn engineering by the
way for accreditation you're going to
spend 75% of your time taking courses
from people with PhDs in science math
and engineering if you look at the kinds
of questions that they examined in all
of those courses in science math and
engineering they're about the
feasibility of ideas what we really
study is is it feasible to do this based
on what we know about the natural law
almost exclusively and on the other hand
if you went to the business school on
the other side of campus and the green
circle they have to spend half of their
time according to the accreditation
standards studying things like
management marketing organization
accounting and that's all about
viability what does this do
to producing dollars okay do you have
enough capital is it legal to do this
how can you sustain it over time it's a
very important set of questions they
don't spend much time over in the blue
circle learning about science what about
the people in the middle though in the
red circle I know about this because
they have a couple daughters that did
this okay so in the red circle this is
where everything else in the university
sits the main campus library people were
majoring in psychology and arts or
humanities so they have a different kind
of question questions like what is the
meaning of love what is the meaning of
truth what is the meaning of beauty
these by way integrating by parts
doesn't help you in this set of
questions neither does having a
spreadsheet are these important
questions these in questions answers to
those questions determine motivation at
the deepest level for all of humans if
people don't choose to do things nothing
happens on a large scale so this is
actually about what people desire what
drives people from the center and the
observation is you have people that we
separate the just look at feasibility
other experts that we separate that just
look advisability and then we have the
people who just think about what's
desirable the problem with that is very
obvious and that is based on work that
was actually done at Stanford all
innovations the kind of innovations that
change the way people in a large scale
only happen at the intersection of all
three I'll bet you can't think of a
single innovation that isn't
simultaneously feasible and viable and
desirable so if you're going to be an
innovator on a large scale you have to
be able to see all of the pieces of the
jigsaw to put them together and if we
only study one kind of piece of the
puzzle it's going to be a rare person
who understands how they all fit and if
we're going to create innovators we new
need to do a better job of integrating
these in the same head so that one
person can see the whole picture
the big message for engineering schools
no amount of doubling down on math and
science courses is going to improve the
output of innovators we're just going to
produce experts in science and math we
have those very cool we need them
they're not innovators now 20th century
innovators require a lot more than
technical knowledge this is a really
important point so for example attitude
plays a really key role entrepreneurial
mindset is a really important attitude
this is an old cliche more often than
not your attitude determines your
altitude in life this guy doesn't even
have legs and he's climbing mountains a
lot better than I ever could by the way
it's not about your aptitude no matter
how good you are it really matters how
determined and how committed you are to
making a success this is the grit part
of what we were talking about this is
what Heckman found is three times more
likely to produce positive outcomes than
what you know so that's this whole thing
of mindset attitudes behaviors and
motivations which is critical to
producing innovation so what do you mean
by mindset well there's a whole list of
them and this I'm not making these up
this is a compendium of what we're
finding from different industries that
are identifying them entrepreneurial
mindset ethical behavior teamwork and
leadership global perspective
interdisciplinary thinking and so on and
so on
by the way the National Academy of
Engineering in the u.s. did a study
recently called educate to innovate this
was the primary conclusion this is
what's missing they're not alone Council
on competitiveness has been putting
together a series of national meetings
on the national engineering forum many
different cities the main outline for
this is is capacity capability and
competitiveness and what's missing and
the capability is this set of mindset
skills stem connector which is a really
interesting group of about five thousand
corporations and organizations working
together to define the work
for us for the 21st century their
conclusion in particular is
employability skills and innovation
excellence is critical if you unpack
that what's it about mindset almost all
the things that they're called for that
are not in the curriculum now and then
iBM has been doing this for at least 25
years the sort of t-shaped person and
the t-shaped person is what it's a
person who has technical depth but has a
mindset set of attitudes and abilities
to work across disciplines and with
people in different fields in order to
integrate those three circles so you can
find the intersection in the middle
that's the idea so all of them are
calling for the same change so one of
the other lessons learned that we found
out well in the u.s. do you know what
fraction of the bachelor's degrees that
are being awarded in the next couple of
months across the United States go to
students who studied any kind of
engineering on any University campus in
America any guesses 4.9 percent okay
four point nine percent the bachelor's
degrees in America to go to kids who get
any kind of engineering degree by the
way about half of the GDP in this
country over the last thirty years has
been produced by those four point nine
percent and this is a bit of a risk
there don't you think and if you look at
it a little more what so why four point
nine percent what's happening and you'll
find out that the students who leave
engineering they come in they're
prepared according to their test scores
and they choose to leave which is
actually 60 percent of the freshmen who
come in nationally to study engineering
never graduate an engineering you might
graduate in something else they're not
in engineering almost half of the ones
who leave have higher grades than the
ones who stayed they're not flunking out
they're choosing to leave why because of
the way we teach it okay it's been it's
been described by a number of our
friends as the math science Death March
okay
look to your left look to your right
it'd be better if at least one of you
wasn't here for the next semester and we
just keep winnowing it down because its
technical superiority that really
matters right that's what we do from the
1950s so how do you fix this after 15
years at Olin we've concluded the best
way to do it is to work on three things
how we teach we're teaching the wrong
people so we're teaching the wrong
people to start with we're teaching the
wrong stuff and we're using teaching
methods that are known to be largely
ineffective otherwise though we're doing
a great job okay
so how do you deal with this one of our
colleagues Tony Wagner at Harvard
recently wrote a book on creating
innovators the making of young people
who will change the world and Tony's
done case studies on this research-based
the bottom line the skill that you need
is learning how to improvise it's the
sort of question that doesn't have a
unique answer it's a question that has
lots of answers that we don't emphasize
enough in the engineering education so
Hoey teach are we attracting the right
people 4.9%
so what about people like Bill Gates
you've heard of Microsoft what about
people like Steve Jobs you've heard of
Apple what about folks like Mark
Zuckerberg you've heard of Facebook
right by the way what does Facebook cell
think about that it's not a you know
it's not a thing what Facebook sells is
an opportunity to tell your personal
story to a group of people who you
really care about
who knew there's a business model in
there I'll tell you who knew Maslow have
you heard of Maslow the psychologist he
did the study on what are the most
important human needs and it turns out
that after oxygen and after water the
next most important need is to be the
most important person in somebody else's
life and the way we have structured our
society today and the way we are
genetically wired is made that very
difficult
you prove that you're the most important
or you the tool you use for creating the
community and the belonging is telling
your personal story and yet as with you
know as people move away on the other
side of the country if you in families
have more kids coming from single-parent
homes there's a lot of need for this
it's basically the inside that made
Facebook work didn't come by the way
from a Nobel Prize in Physics it came
from that red circle undesirability so
it's people in that space that had by
the way how many of these guys were
engineers zero none of them majored in
engineering math science death march
didn't seem like it was relevant to what
they wanted to do maybe we're not
attracting the right people we need by
the way if we're going to attract the
right people we need a broader
definition of what it means to be an
engineer in the 21st century if you look
at definitions in the dictionary it says
engineers who are people who contrive a
solution to a problem using a science ok
how many kids are gonna wake up in the
morning and say that's what I want to do
ok our definition of an engineering by
the way engineering is not a body of
knowledge our kids taught us that that
involves knowledge there's no question
about that it's not a body of knowledge
Engineering is a process have you heard
of the aircraft industry you know the
guys who developed that were the Wright
brothers so the Wright brothers were
actually two bicycle mechanics in Ohio
how did they do it they jumped off a
hill a zillion times with these wings on
their back and they kept crashing and
they said well there must be a better
way to do this so they changed something
and they keep doing until they get a
little farther down the hill eventually
they developed the field of aeronautics
who then the physicists and university
said oh I guess you can't fly when
you're heavier than air I wonder Hawaii
and they began to ask the questions that
develop the theory so experimentation
often precedes theory in the development
of new technologies and engineering is
the process of iterative improvement on
ideas
we do this in one course usually at the
end of the program which we call the
capstone and kids are supposed to just
like have an epiphany and understand oh
that's what all this was about
and did this for the rest of their life
you know what Olin College the average
graduate completes 25 projects before
they graduate they start a business and
they also work for a company for a year
they do this all in four years and by
the way Stanford is one of the most
popular places for Olin graduates to go
to continue their graduate work which is
not the same in their undergraduate
program and so they make that transition
with much less concern than you would
think we need multiple intelligences so
an engineer at Olin is a person who
envisions what has never been and does
whatever it takes to make it happen by
the way
I'm here because of my math teacher in
high school she said you know you're
good at math so maybe you should be an
engineer whatever that is by the way I
had never met an engineer or a person
with a PhD until I was a freshman at the
University of California so I ran into
one I still not sure what they are
honestly but apparently it has something
to do with math okay our definition it
doesn't even mention math it starts with
vision if you can't envision it you will
never make it that's basically where it
starts with it starts with vision you
might be a terrific applied scientist or
applied mathematician but you're not
going to change the world if you don't
have vision secondly you need to have
the determination whatever takes the
grit to hang in there to get the funding
for it to get the team together to get
the prototype to fly and to sell it to
the rest of the world else it's not
going to work that's what an engineer is
they start with vision and they have
Drive so that's the people we need
secondly what we teach but wait a minute
if you're trained as an engineer you
know what we teach right this is about
statics and dynamics it's about strength
of materials it's about stress analysis
is about basic electrical circuits
it's about thermodynamics fluid
mechanics all that stuff that's what it
means to be
right well are we teaching the rights is
this the right stuff who knows the
answer to that the people who are
practicing is engineers who Wars are who
were our students and are now out in
industry turns out that recently for
example the thesis at MIT
Kristin wolf did a study of the alumni
from their engineering department what
did they find out I don't have time to
go through the whole thing in this they
found out that what they did not learn
at MIT but was used pervasively in their
career within five years were these
things
teamwork communications professional
skills personal skills independent
thinking sound look familiar
did we see that before on that list of
mindset skills this is not what they
were taught this is what they were
actually required to be expert in this
is how their career advancement goes
forward by the way these are not
technical subjects this is what they
taught at MIT mechanical engineering and
their graduates said well we learned
this but really really seldom do we
actually use this stuff unless you're
actually going to be a professor of
engineering at MIT this might not be the
right list of stuff that you should
learn I happen to also be on a panel at
the National Academy of Engineering
right now looking at the engineering
education workforce continue what goes
forward there's data where you ask
engineers across broad industry so this
is not MIT the number one thing if you
ask them how do you spend your time
designing the number two thing managing
people solving equations and dealing
with the physics is way down the list
now it's important don't get me wrong
I'm not saying we don't teach that stuff
I'm saying we're emphasizing the wrong
stuff and by omission we're sending the
message that they're not important these
are hard sciences so maybe we should
rethink what the content is and finally
and I'm almost at the end here how we
teach so okay so let's agree that we
need to attract the people who are not
normally attracted to engineering by
starting with vision
and in expecting them to be innovators
secondly let's assume that the curtain
that the curriculum content needs to be
revised somehow so that we still have
rigor and we still have science and math
but it has like 25 projects involved
rather than one at the end still have
the question of how do you teach what's
the best way to teach today there's lots
of information on this what I will focus
on is one of the books that I think is
really interesting this is a book that
has as a co-author John Seely Brown so
anybody heard of John Seely Brown yeah
he's like he's from the valley right
this guy was the chief technology
officer at Xerox and the founder of
Xerox PARC the Carroll Alto Research
Center were computing these personal
computing was invented in his years
after Xerox he's been really consumed
with understanding how people learn and
what technology can do at the
intersection so John's book a new
culture of learning kind of lays this
out if you look at the old model and the
new model side-by-side one of the things
that you find out is the old model was
about transferring knowledge remember
that picture with a arrow going into the
kid's head that's what this does the new
model it's about teaching people to
construct knowledge in their head so
it's new to them it may not be new to
the world but they learn how to
construct these models day after day in
addition to this the old model is about
sending a message you have to have the
prerequisites you have to do it this way
in this order you can't do that yet
because you haven't had all the right
courses so that's why we have the
capstone course where you actually
design something in the senior year
because apparently you break some kind
of log nature if you pick up a wrench
before you've had two years of calculus
and physics okay can't do that's the
main message a subliminal message the
new model is about can do it's
empowering you to try things the old
model said follow orders put your pencil
down test is over don't talk to your
neighbors the new model is about
following your passions this is about
you envision
something that you're really interested
in and then you empower yourself to go
and find the data and make it work the
old model is about learning in class
that's why it's important to show up on
time and to attend every class is way
attendance is so important okay the new
model you learn 24/7 class is just one
of the places you learn the old model
was you learn alone don't talk to your
neighbor don't share your data that's
cheating the new model is about teamwork
it's about learning from others and
building communities of learning and
finally the old model is about
problem-based learning that's important
right solving problems the new model is
about design based learning well what's
the difference okay well they both
involve making things that don't exist
now problem-based learning is what I
would call painting by numbers
remember those kits when you were a kid
it's like a coloring book there's black
and white with lines and they put little
numbers in the boxes and you put colors
of the right color inside the box then
you make a painting that's project-based
somebody had to pre digest it know how
many parts that were make sure your kit
had all the stuff you need it's better
than not doing any kind of construction
it's not the same thing design based
learning is a blank sheet of paper okay
you have to decide what to draw how big
it should be what colors it should be it
exercises in fact a different part of
the brain it's that creative visioning
part of the brain that's missing right
now yeah that's what John Sadie Brown
says by the way I claim that's not new
we've been doing this for generations
that's very much the template of what we
do in graduate school that's how a ph.d
program works you do a little bit of
coursework and you do this sort of
weekly independent study you talk to the
faculty remember you are the one who
generates the vision and the drive it's
because so you care about this you learn
independently you talk to the other
graduate students and you eventually
present your work that's not new oh but
you say that's only I only work in
graduate school you have to be you know
really advanced in order to be able to
learn this way I have a question for you
have you ever heard of the Montessori
schools
okay those are five-year-olds and by the
way did you know the disproportionate
number of CEOs of major corporations are
graduates of Montessori schools
apparently they didn't get damaged too
badly by this process okay
what's missing is in the middle it's the
bachelors degree the undergraduate
program where we're losing remember four
point nine percent that 95 percent of
the kids who are not doing it are being
structured out of it because of the math
science Death March okay my most
favorite quote from the book is this one
for most of the 20th century our
educational system is built on the
assumption that teaching is necessary
for learning to occur okay it's not okay
you're able to learn on your own without
any teacher that's why kids don't come
to class and they still pass because
they know how to learn on their own is
that a bad thing finally one of my
favorite quotes from dr. Charles vest
who was one of our heroes chuck was the
not only the president of MIT for 14
years but who's also the president of
the National Academy of Engineering his
thinking on this making universities and
engineering schools exciting creative
adventurous rigorous demanding and
empowering millou's in other words the
culture is far more important than in
specifying any curricular details so my
message is don't copy what Olin does
invent your own process make sure you
create the culture where that's what
people say at Olin what we've discovered
if you buttonhole kids at the water
cooler and talk to them they'll tell you
two things almost without exception I've
never worked this hard in my life at
anything what one is not a party school
by the way
Princeton Review writes Olin number two
in the US for the students study harder
than others so it's just a drudgery
workhorse right no the second thing they
tell you there's nothing else I'd rather
be doing when you get those two things
together I've never
work this hard and there's nothing else
I'd rather be doing you've now lit the
fire of independent learning on their
own that's the culture we need to be
building so what's happened at Olin this
is the last slide Olin turns out
Princeton Review last year identified
Olin as having the best classroom
experience in America and this is not
just engineering schools this is all
universities so NBC Today Show had a
segment on Olin and so forth number two
for the students study the most it's
what I was just explaining number 19 the
happiest students and I think we're the
only engineering school in the u.s. that
has been ranked in the top 20 in both of
those things there are lots of schools
that have hard workers there are also
schools that are have happy students but
not at the same time that's what you
need to be working at you might wonder
you must be losing something
okay I've given these talks before with
politically with faculty members look if
they did 25 projects they can't have as
many technical elective courses with the
advanced you know pre PhD graduate work
so they're they're just they're not
going to be prepared for doing the
really rigorous science and math right
well maybe not last spring one year ago
one one of the Olin graduates from
Austin Texas was the first Olin student
to win a Marshall scholarship now a
Marshall scholarship has the same
statistics as the Rhodes
they're 34 of them in the u.s. they go
to the UK the differences in the
Marshall you can study in any University
the road you study at Rock at the road
scholarship you study at Oxford so what
this guy did is he went to Cambridge
University to study physics with in the
same lab as Stephen Hawking an
interesting thing Olin doesn't offer
physics okay
we don't have a degree in physics he
prepared himself for that through this
engine of learning how to study on your
own and he convinced the folks at
Cambridge that he's ready to do this
so maybe teaching is not necessary for
learn
to occur maybe students are capable of
learning on their own okay with that I
think I will stop and I will answer any
questions that people have if you're
still awake
okay key question what are the barriers
to implementing these ideas in other
schools well every school is different
but all of them seem to have some
similar concerns okay
and it's basically faculty attitudes
that the here's the thing you in every
University that has tenure and has
academic freedom you don't change the
curriculum unless the tenured faculty
vote on it that's those are the people
you need to persuade and the faculty
members in spite of the fact that they
have academic freedom are not prone to
take risk okay and they're and it's not
that they're not concerned about change
and about innovation and creativity I
think they're rightly worried that to
make such a radical change we might be
losing something really important to the
students so one of the things that we
need is better assessment data on this
kind of a model across other
universities so that you can be really
confident that if you prepare them in
this new way you didn't hurt them in
some way they are in fact advantaged and
the assessment data is still in process
so that's that's one of the most
important barriers yep not aligned with
Blake undergraduate education like at
the top research schools I've noticed
that most of the faculty focus on
researching writing grants and they
don't really see anything for
undergraduate classes yes so this is a
very good comment it's in addition to
the fact that they may be worried about
outcomes for students that faculty
members are not incentivized in
for working on teaching as much as they
are for example working on research and
I think that's right one of the things
that we've been worried about this
happened at Olin you know so if I do
this will it count I mean are you going
to punish me by the way this is also a
little bit of a red herring okay this is
not how innovation happens look let's
make make the whole world flat and then
we can dry design a car okay what you do
is the pioneers are people who know that
their barriers and they put themselves
at risk and they prove against all odds
that it does work and then people
reluctantly say what are we going to do
about John I mean he changed the world
it's not in our manual okay we're not
supposed to reward that well maybe we
need to amend the manual to take care of
John and if you look at case studies
that's how it actually works there are
ways to fix this so the most important
work that happened at Olin in the last
two years is reinventing the faculty
manual what does that mean every
University that we've been to including
the four that I've been at in my career
has a promotion criteria that involves
three things teaching research and
service this is documented in the
dossier which is a you know a three-ring
binder that has three tabs so our folks
said this is not well aligned with what
needs to happen let's throw it away and
let's redesign it from the beginning
so at Olin what happened we don't have
three tabs we have a Venn diagram that
has three circles they intersect instead
of talking about service which usually
means you know working on a committee we
talk about building the institution
instead of talking about teaching we
talk about building Student Success
whatever that means
it includes mentoring and includes even
working with alumni it's not just about
teaching scores in your teaching
portfolio and the most important one
about research so we've replaced
research with nationally visible impact
with what you do outside of the
community now researching Park is one of
the ways you can do that
working on committees is one of the ways
you can show service and getting good
teaching evaluations is one of the ways
that you can show that you're building
student success but there are lots of
others
case in point one of our faculty members
built the case for promotion by in fact
generating letters from deans and
presidents of three other universities
who said that because of this person's
work on their campus they were
successful at changing their whole
undergraduate educational program it
would not have been possible without
this person's leadership do you think
that's nationally visible impact so in
our case that's equivalent to a faculty
member who got a letter from a journal
editor and from three department chairs
who said you know John's work was among
the five best in the world in his age
group so that's so it's just not you
know we're not breaking any natural laws
as far as I can tell you know Newton's
law still work the only barrier between
this is the will and the creative
impulse of the folks who have to make
decisions yes k12 schooling has been
trying to teach 21st century skills
which include most of what you said for
a long time yes and have not really
succeeded yeah and you're you're even
saying further you want to do without
teachers in a sense can you maybe
explain a bit how how you're doing it
yes so the the question was well some
experience in some k-12 schools trying
to teach these mindset skills have not
been successful at least people don't
believe that they're successful at this
point so what is only doing that
succeeds right well number one I we
don't have enough time for me to give
you a complete answer so my my answer
that has come and visit us okay number
one add so we've got 640 universities
have done it let's make it 641 okay the
only way you're going to really know it
is to talk to the people and see the
students themselves it's a culture thing
it's the last slide from Chuck FASST
about creating this milieu so that's
about values that's about alignment of
purpose
that's about it relentless focus on
student success along the way so there's
a lot of answers of that in terms of
Total Immersion for one of the things
that we do I'm sure that a lot of things
that Olin does are not necessary okay
because we've seen a lot of this change
happen at the University of Illinois at
urbana-champaign and they only made like
10 percent of the total Olin kool-aid
then they in Institute there so I'm kind
of reluctant to go through the
outrageous things that Olin does from
candidates weekend in terms of selecting
the right people to the total immersion
environment every student is required to
live in the residence hall for all four
years it enables teamwork on weekends
you know every faculty member so the
most the simplest thing I can say to any
University who is serious about
improving the quality of teaching does
not cost a dime and you don't need
geniuses to do it the two things ask the
faculty members to sit through the
courses they assign the students to take
okay isn't that amazing
this is a Yogi Berra thing you know it's
amazing what you can see by looking all
of that coherence and the way the jigsaw
all felt to fit together that you
deduced from looking at you know a small
paragraph in the catalog to describe
what the course does actually doesn't
work as well if you're sitting in the
seat of students the second thing that
we ask every time you bring a new
faculty member in before they've been
deployed on their own to teach their
specialty for the first year they should
be assigned to teach in teams with
faculty members from another discipline
the only thing they have in common
is teaching and the students it's not
about being the expert on the stage this
changes like 50% of the problem that
needs to be dealt with changes the
culture okay yes sir what were some
things that you tried during your
partner session with those like 15 30
kids that you thought would work
really not working okay so here's that
like the first thing we did we got the
founding faculty members together small
room we so got this big job we have to
rethink what it means to be educated and
engineer and so forth and we ask them
what you could you remember from your
own undergraduate experience that was an
interesting question you know a little
embarrassing well I remember I had
physics but I'm not sure I think was
Holliday and Resnick but I don't you
know I don't ask me to do quantum
mechanics today it's been a long time
but everybody without exception could
remember in stunning detail the senior
project that they were working on
decades afterwards in fact I can even
remember what I was eating at the time
the breakthrough idea occurred to me why
it didn't work okay all these years
later
so we said cheese you know the
difference in retention and understand
real understanding of what you gain from
the project was like orders of magnitude
greater than the coursework okay
so why did you wait to the senior year
to do this project because everybody
waited to the senior year there wasn't a
single person in the room that had that
in the sophomore year well there must be
a reason probably probably it has to do
with two years of calculus and physics
right then if he picked up a wrench
before you had two years of calculus and
physics I mean I liked it cause a black
hole or something that would absorb the
earth some really disastrous thing would
happen because nobody does it so we
decided okay well we'll do an experiment
let's try this so we had those 15 boys
and 15 girls so look they don't know
that you can't do this so let's see what
happens we assigned them a challenge
like right after they came they had just
graduated from high school had no
college at all we said we want you kids
to design build and demonstrate a pulse
oximeter and we want you to do that in
five weeks
they said excuse me what's a pulse
oximeter you know so we spelled out the
word and we said this is a medical
instruments that thing you find in the
hospital nowhere they clip it on your
finger and it measures the pulse rate
and the oxygen content your butt well
that way it doesn't have a needle it
doesn't stick in you it has a light look
through the skin and you know if you
want to know more about this we suggest
you go to the Internet and look it up on
the on the patent literature the person
who invented this has to have a little
schematic diagram and in a one-page
description of how it works and they
said okay cool you know where to we'll
go off and start to do this but so you
got five weeks to do this and then we're
going to move on and do some other
experiment and if you have questions you
know we're here but we're not going to
give you lectures on how to do this
there's a shop over there that has
soldering irons and transistors whatever
those things are and it's up to you so
we figured five weeks is enough time to
get in serious trouble
okay after five weeks it could be so
frustrated so we will end it in five
weeks what we sort of considered a mercy
killing okay and then we'll do the purse
post-mortem so where do they get stuck
on semiconductor physics didn't even
know what physics is turns out in five
weeks they had wasn't working they built
it okay so we brought in a hospital
version and calibrated them next to each
other and they're doing the same thing I
mean it was amazing now don't get me
wrong
they weren't physicists and they weren't
really technicians either it's kind of a
miracle that this thing worked if you
look to the soldering it's just drops of
stuff all over they had a box full of
fried transistors that all blew up I
mean because they had why does it have
three wires sticking out the back so
they couldn't explain a lot of this but
they can make it work okay now we should
have known that they could do that if we
had been real engineers and not
academics we would have expected them
because that's the way all engineering
works is by trial and error and until
you get something to work but you know
we expected you need to have all this
theory first there was something else we
learned which was way more important
what we learned is that this experience
of exceeding their own expectations and
making something like that work changed
who they are it was as if they were two
feet taller now
there was the sense of can-do since it I
can change the world now if I have a
group of people like me a shop to go
experiment and a couple of old guys to
ask questions once in a while
anything I can imagine I can do and then
we compared that with the way we felt as
first-year students in engineering
school it was not a can-do attitude okay
it was as as John Seely Brown says it
was a can't do attitude to me and not
even knowing what an engineer was I
thought they were people who made stuff
and when I enrolled at the University of
California in those days I was amazed at
the first year that we never made
anything it was like well go take all
this physics and calculus alright so
they moved the goalposts we're gonna do
it in the second year right come back in
the second year go take some more
physics and math he kept doing that so
it was an attitudinal thing which fueled
the change in culture in the development
of these students